Imagine isto. O seu chefe diz, por favor, mudem as cadeiras de lugar.
Uma pessoa move cinco cadeiras, outra pessoa move todas as cadeiras da sala,
outra pessoa não move nenhuma porque pensou que era para amanhã.
Quem cometeu o erro?
Talvez ninguém.
Talvez o problema não tenha sido o esforço,
talvez o problema tenha sido a comunicação.
As grandes equipas não trabalham apenas com a Fink.
As grandes equipas comunican com clareza.
A comunicação é uma das competências mais valiosas que alguma vez irá aprender.
Poupa tempo, previne erros, constrói confiança
e ajuda as pessoas a gostarem de trabalhar em conjunto.
O maior erro de comunicação é este.
Nós presumimos.
Presumimos que percebemos.
Presumimos que a outra pessoa percebeu.
Presumimos que toda a gente está a pensar a mesma coisa.
A maioria dos problemas começa com suposições.
A solução é simples.
Faça perguntas de clarificação.
Por exemplo, só quero confirmar se percebi bem.
Pode mostrar-me o que quer dizer?
Como é que se define sucesso aqui?
Para quando precisa disto pronto?
É esta maior prioridade?
Estes não são sinais de fraqueza, são sinais de profissionalismo.
Deixe-me dar-lhe outro exemplo.
O seu chefe diz.
Por favor, limpe a cozinha.
Uma pessoa lava a loiza.
Outra limpa o chão.
Outra limpa as bancadas.
Outras vazia o lixo.
Todos trabalharam com afinco.
Mas todos tinham uma ideia diferente do que significava limpar a cozinha.
Uma conversa de dois minutos podia ter poupado 30 minutos de confusão.
Uma boa comunicação é mais rápida do que corrigir erros.
Agora vamos falar sobre escutar.
Muitas pessoas escutam para poderem responder.
As grandes pessoas escutam para poderem compreender.
Quando alguém está a falar, pare o que está a fazer.
Olhe para a pessoa.
Escute com atenção.
Não interrompa.
Quando terminar, repita o que ouviu.
Por exemplo, então se percebi bem, gostaria que eu terminasse isto antes do almoço.
Chama-se a isto, confirmar a sua compreensão.
É um dos hábitos mais simples das grandes equipas.
Outro hábito importante é fazer o ponto da situação.
Se uma tarefa demora várias horas ou vários dias, não desapareça.
Envie uma mensagem.
Vala a ter.
Pergunte.
Só confirmar.
Isto continua a ser a prioridade?
Ou este é o meu progresso.
Estou no caminho certo?
Pequenos pontos de situação evitam grandes problemas.
Lembre-se disto.
As mais notícias não melhoram com o tempo.
Se algo estiver atrasado, se cometer um erro, se não percebe algo, fale cedo.
As pessoas podem ajudar a resolver um problema que conhecem.
Não podem resolver um problema que não sabem que existe.
Por fim, lembre-se de que a comunicação tem a ver com respeito.
Quando comunica com clareza, respeita o tempo dos outros.
Quando escuta com atenção, respeita a outra pessoa.
Quando faz perguntas, respeita o trabalho.
Quando confirma sua compreensão, respeita a missão.
Por isso, hoje, quero que se lembre de quatro hábitos simples.
Primeiro, não presuma.
Segundo, faça perguntas de clarificação.
Terceiro, repita o que percebeu.
Quarto, faça pontos de situação cedo e com frequência.
Estes quatro hábitos vão torná-lo um melhor colega de equipa.
Vão torná-lo mais digno de confiança.
Vão ajudá-lo a crescer na sua carreira.
E vão ajudar toda a nossa equipa a ter sucesso em conjunto.
Uma boa comunicação não tem a ver com usar palavras difíceis.
Tem a ver com garantir que as pessoas se compreendem umas às outras.
Comunique com clareza.
Escute com atenção.
Esclareça com frequência.
Porque as grandes equipas não adivinham.
As grandes equipas comunicam.